we don't want two Arts we don't want a
weapon work and then our
body so we know I have two Hand Works I
have the our spiral and the EM spiral
our spiral is the wrist goes out the El
comes
in spiral wrist comes in elbow goes out
this hand is doing your outward
spiral right
hand the left hand is doing your in
spiral it's just very small now
okay I walk my first
angle to take
advantage that he's playing seon so he's
going to be slightly up at my
throat this exposes bottom of the weapon
so I F the in
space I go around the
contestation and attack the hands so the
angle
up is your defensive path of action
should anything go south I got there
cool I come around I generate the angle
of attack on the hands and attack The
Stance and then it's just IDI from
don't land here the move's not done
or is
drop you want to attack his stance
the hand comes down exactly where it
does that
show rotate
rotate from
me come on
okay on his
side just like if you're to PM me in the
face that's not can he goes did I move
my
body same thing
here go I'm hold this and not Y into the
Y
to into the Y
he's trying to check me but I'm going to
uncheck Myself by not contesting but not
losing
contact everything is relaxed stuck I
have my base again I can
okay there's a lot
there don't get stuck in the stomach
don't get your hands broken don't lose
connection don't get
pinned he tries to stick you in the
stomach he tries to pin here he tries to
hit your hands you can slow it down but
we can't change the mechanics we're
working with
don't pick up
anymore don't pick it up if he's going
to parallel then you let it go to
parallel it's pulling on your right
shoulder right now so bend your knees
more so it doesn't fall on your right
shoulder stay connected
I lift
up okay p
settle let everything drop release it's
like the show don't start over right
away
okay down down down down down down keep
your
balance don't don't give up the Top Line
parallel to the
deck not two steps one
step one step on Theo
all right uh because we have in
mid-range grappling we have a concept of
of stick and follow so he I if I make
contact with him I'm going to touch his
Center and there it is right there he's
going to have to get off of this the
stick part so that's why I follow okay
and then
boom so it might look
like I'm not necessarily defending
myself because I'm underneath but I
regain the initiative as long as I don't
lose connection because wherever he goes
I'm going to follow it to the next
opening okay so he goes boom and I'm
here he comes forward it's not going to
happen he goes up you're just up and you
follow
it but if you get checked out then he
did what he's supposed to do even if I
didn't get my my hands hit
okay to do this I can't wait here too
late he's already checking
me the M change too watch his chest he's
already that much closer I haven't even
moved you have to get connection already
with him so I'm moving with his chest so
I'm going to have you focus on the chest
to chest metric
don't pick it
up Let It Go where he stops that's where
I stop he he doesn't feel any lift on
him there's no space okay try it again
that's B don't come off don't come off
go to
parallel push
down don't come off don't lift up
down put your right hand underneath your
uh Center Line don't come forward
under your Center Line that's
it breath in breath out
use the right hand to do your torch not
the Left
Right sett your the low leg tension
you
straight Center Line Center Line Center
Line Center Line Center Line looks to
the to your
left is
J okay good
[Music]
he's turn to off this this
Joe is going to represent the resistance
of his Mass upon hitting it okay you
could be an any
Bas so he's trying I'll do it try to
walk
forward okay this is the mass of the
target does everyone understand that if
I if I try to hit this there's an equal
and opposite reaction that has to over
overcome in order to displace it
okay and that is being represented
here if he
walks like
that he will and he happen to hit me in
in there or I came forward or I resist
in any way that foot will not get on the
ground again really TR
you put it in the
back and try to walk through and when he
gets up his balance will be taken back
he could put it in the
front and he could do
Tui same thing what I want to
do is shift my weight to the Yar on the
back
leg and drive this foot forward
so this isn't me Landing
here I foot
relative watch's the
difference falling into
it pushing into it
so in Parker would call this a step
dve this was a
push
right
step
Drive
push drive we want to
push down push
not your
weight down
push watch my head on the step
dry push
dry setep
dry push dry
telegraphing going change
Dimensions harder to tell that your
depth changing add verticality to it and
his pration eyes is more easily
detecting range is changing okay so if
you T yourself with head one
level probably do the if you don't care
you're probably doing this
St what is the push
drive back leg knee to Y and the whole
back fo
it for okay try it again
right hand under
Center s
the don't just hit
start shrinking your spirals more and
more and more
try to keep try to bring less and less
verticality into it
less and less
telegraphing small spir don't point the
tip down you'll expose the spine keep it
parallel to the
okay let's understand this strategically
okay uh so let's say this dude
is getting all in my face I'm like hey I
don't want any trouble he keeps doing
this get
it I don't want any trouble keep
doing that is the nature of this stru
okay this
is your
initiating attack a couple
things you have to hide it as long as
possible don't Telegraph it so the
verticality is a way of hiding it as
long as possible
watch your hesitation when it's time to
move you have to move
so not
here you're
here and it moves from
here watch your
inhale the
telegraphs watch your shoulders coming
up watch your face changing the
expression okay the same the same way
that I'm if I did the release drill I am
already ready to push on the back fo
okay so we're going to add that to
it here and you're going to see I don't
want you to kill each other but you're
going to work
on you're hiding of the stri by doing
these things no T so everything's very
loose and you're off
and second thing don't let the foot drag
open because now you're heel weight the
foot can only go kns open to the
90 Mass close to the
45 careful that you forget the foot
behind and it opens on you bring the
foot with you
hands
drag step sorry push it comes with
me comes with okay try
to explosive no telegraphing bring the
foot with you short your spirals First
Strike very very
economical no hesitation in
mind no face no shoulders Rising no
change in breath
smaller
spirals bring the back foot with
you and settle at the end before you
reset
smaller
spiral so travel left through all three
planes
down
down make sure your shoulders not
checked don't lift up on
him the shoulder is very relaxed and
dropped on the bul end
[Music]
down
he's it's not your turn to yield it's
your turn to
train you got it so you felt him resist
I would have rather that you teach him
that that was a Class D okay right
watch your foot watch your
[Music]
base all
right so uh when I move
I should be able to move
again
so so if if I drop and I checked myself
that this is not the point okay and the
way I don't check myself is the settling
the settling there's going to be a
rebound and I use the rebound to move be
able to move
me don't you change the move and go no
BL and then you're
going you your strategy here again we're
just fting is I'm going to check his way
and now I can attack CU he's not as
mobilized okay it's the strategy that's
the strategy of a
toou so I drop I'm
okay try it K
is just the back rall with the same
ukami uh that you always have to do so
he has to Yin yield so here he Yin yield
and here he
Yin I shouldn't be touching him in the
ribs
y
okay try to slow it first
go stay connected
is just like the buid I don't go flying
away I don't get stabed
don't go flying away don't get
stabed keep your spine from De necting
[Music]
keep go chase him down chase him down
so think about it technically you get
out of the way I didn't stab him you
understand that so I checked
enough that I'm here he didn't get St so
I'm not going to stop I'm going to now
the Su of the spear into breaking
balance you got
it you got out of
it so I'm more dynamic in my movement
boom Chase
Chase okay I'll have you in here to help
you not get stuck
okay remember what we're trying to do
here is make sure I'm heavy but Dynamic
okay not just heavy and stiff heavy and
immobile no no that's
wrong and settle before you get out like
the chase sink again at the end don't
start over right away
keep your right hand under your
Center move your body don't move your
hands keep it under your Center put your
left foot forward left foot forward so
you're not all twisted that left foot
forward under your Center you have the
same exact handw work you have from the
beginning
[Music]
keep your hand under your Center move
your body not your hands
no time to change hands you in your
right hand
sometimes you can hit the M sometimes
you can't
you want to hit the with your left
foot right hand under Center
okay now I really want you to not get
tapped not get checked okay got it
you're going to still allow for the same
it wouldn't really be there okay they're
going to keep doing the move but you're
going to work on didn't got it no pull
no jerk no stiff shoulder just
disappears in the
void okay
to bring your mind to your body to your
feet to your right
shoulder good
okay see if you can just walk
out but you have to you have to check on
and then you have to yield got it you
don't un yield so he can walk out you
check you do your move you neutralize
and you should be able to walk out okay
TR you need to slow down down to say can
you slow down that's perfectly fine but
we don't start milking
it wait Did you feel the
pull on your shoulder on your right
shoulder
slower but that would be the
amplification process so if I send the
if I he throws a ball boom okay the fact
that the ball goes flying is telling you
that the ball was resisting the bat
swing okay so if my sword goes
flying then I was resisting the the
joke okay as he's
going he should land in the void that's
what he HS
he hits nothing but I'm not doing
this do the whole
technique okay try it again
more loose loose
loose you guys judge did I feel it in my
shoulder did I feel it in my shoulder am
I moving like nobody who ever fought for
their life move do do you understand
somebody comes shoot it in here you're
freaking going to move you're not going
to
go right you guys got it okay try it
again
it's got to be natural movement
and keep your tip parallel to the deck
don't lift it up don't let him lift it
up you're wait wait go
back you're already F SW
down all
right all
right so what we did there is what we
did on t one we amplify the forces so we
can see a little bit more of ourselves
okay so we're going to do something else
now we can slow it back down reduce the
amplification okay so he's doing that
move I yeld he comes in I just grab grab
it okay grab
it and I'll do a choing cut chopping
Cuts work on the
neck he hits boid comes in boom chop
keep this don't go around it till you
know he's coming forward keep this till
you know he's coming forward then
he okay
try going back down
work
clear the clear the
line leave his weapon at zero pressure
don't drop your tip till he's coming
forward
right
okay so his
energy I
yield
right his energy don't move
it I move this way I leave it there
until I grab it
then it comes into the cut
boom his energy my contestation line
that I work
[Music]
with I try not to feel his
strength go around all his strength
[Music]
to do this
cut boom it comes
forward you see I move myself under
it now it's back on top of my head and
then I bring my elbow in
boom don't bring your elbow
out elbow comes
in the side
boom Swit
sides don't feel their power not they
dropping power not linear power go
around
it draw draw pull the Jo
in that's
it you need more space you can decide
how far you go around how separated your
feet are but the body must be obey
again I know it feels weird to you but
you have to imagine there's a third
team elbow elbow leads elbow elow leads
the cut not it this see how you have no
room your elbows behind him the elbow
leads the
cut elbow
leaves put keep your weight on the front
foot that's the cutting
foot don't overlan it
okay uh I have a
rule he gets one step I get one step
okay he gets two steps I get two steps
if he takes one step and I take three
steps
timing okay so for
example that is why on the first move I
don't want him doing a front crossover
and then the move see that or two sugii
two shuffles one two
no I'm not going to be there so he does
the front crossover number
he does two shuffles
same you guys one I get one likewise go
slow he's coming here see he did one I
did one he's coming around
boom
boom not
that's all you have to find the mod in
that okay that's all you get all right
try it
again you have EDI K you're on the Udi
ankle Udi tenom that's it nope that's
two
tenom stay on the
45 stay on that
45 stay on that 45
okay so these aren't life Sabers
okay let's just look at what he was
doing wait going do the whole movement
from the start I'm not
there and you're going to pretend you're
going to that guy up all the way
down you got it
Go everyone got it that that's what he
was doing right
yeah let's say I did Nick
him what do you think is he going to go
in or is he getting off the cut he's
getting off the cut
okay
so just slow and you'll see that why I
like that
angle keep
going got it
that's why my
elbow is in front not behind behind his
body you're going to you're going to run
into that
thing this instead he cuts
himself on my sword okay try it again
you want to be at the ad angle what I
mean by that is you're at the 45 to the
line of attack the 4:00 angle in this
case 4 to 10 okay yeah elbows in front
of him it will be if you don't contest
his
weapon I think what I see is that you
are losing the chest to
chest as it starts and so they're
closing a lot more than they ever should
have as their chest moves you're already
moving to keep them ey and not give him
the advantage of now being closer to you
with the longer weapon okay go back
yes in front of him with your elbow in
front of him at the
45 and let him run into that
way elb
in learn it if you need to use your left
foot to yield
can you can enter come back you can
enter come forward okay
[Music]
picture he's he's rning me make sure
that you're not you're not ob one and
you're swinging a thing dud right into
you look at your head now
okay dra in the space
you you're entering too far on your on
your TD you know what you need to hit to
don't enter this
[Applause]
arbitrarily the
even if you don't grab it and you
probably
can't you still hook it so that it comes
into you okay so I wouldn't take my
sweet I wouldn't what's what's my main
thing right there do you see that's my
main goal I'm just adding to
things right that's just
adding don't do your
contingencies you see before you do your
primary work the work the draw
boom that is more important
elbow in front
okay did you ever have
tennis what happens is every time you
hit this part and is working against
this
part it's no
different and no stri cool and I'm going
here hitting here see it's just very
very slow well when he does a hand Sword
and the Hand leads the same things
happen Okay this is going to stop this
is going to go forward okay so we're
going to do some Discovery learning and
just feel
that there he is and you're going to do
the
last okay try
make this last around your head
you both done
10 then you're going to go here
try 10 times did I hit
him just pushing with
it push with
it push with it
you're just standing
there don't don't absorb you're our
weight bar again we're not killing you
absorb just them move you they have to
move
you and don't don't move don't move in
with a push not going to go here and
then turn it this I use the same angle
and I move him he's going that
way not
here okay
try two two sets of 10
on and don't absorb make them move here
[Music]
I'm not telling you to fight being moved
I'm just telling you don't they'll move
you you don't have to do anything but
accept it see that foot that would be a
fight all right let them move you that's
it all
right don't stop you being moved but
don't make yourself move don't stop
yourself being
moved but let yourself be moved don't
stop yourself being moved just ride the
energy till it's out of your
body that's better don't tense up
they're not hitting you just be moved
keep your arm on the circle so your hand
should come back to you
okay last around your head
this way this send it on that way keep
your foot right foot forward no more
stepping in there go around your head
and bring him to
me there you
go more to
do bring
leave your hand in the knife edge don't
Palm he
it okay
do you feel a difference between your
two
elbows yes or no might not might not be
sens okay all right what we're going to
do now is look at it
mechanically I come around I do the lass
around my head where's my
elbow it's outside my outer rim you see
that nothing my
face here comes my weapon back in
yourand comes up just
like inside your
OU then the elbow comes
in does not have the elbow go out
standing like
this okay you go like this just like
your right hook always beginners
no you're never going to hit with that
you need get
C the right hook you're going to have to
move and it just turns
over same similar concept don't take
away your defense to do your
offense so the weapon comes
up my elbow goes in and rest
right up elbow
when you guys are going like this did
you notice that you wanted to do that
okay that's what you do
here not ever there up
up up
Eloy up like showman Eloy
now Bo
up elbow in up elbow in slow down yes up
elbow
in elb up elbow in stay it in your head
up elbow
in up elbow
in a much more compact
stri up elbow
in up El up
el el
so when I'm doing
this I
I'm I'm still going to hit in the same
place the the question is how did you
get
there and where's your elbow when you
are there that's the only difference
okay my elbow's over
here not down
here I got there going up and bringing
my elbow to
there but is still
hidden
hits
hits now boom up hits
boom up
up out in up elbow
anchor boom okay try it
again there not at the right height you
can lower them okay you can you can only
hit the target you can hit that are open
to you you can change your height keep
the form
okay so what would be your intention
with this stri if you were to hit
aord with our hand yeah
yeah yeah but what what are we shooting
for Lev of Consciousness
or it's not going to cut off the head
right they not going to cut off so that
can't be something I want there's things
I don't want okay what I want should be
conducive to what the strike the nature
of the strike
okay
so um
my direction of my weapon pay attention
is going to be its furthest from my
spine line
when use your use your
geometry no on my body come on I'm not
giving it to you it's so freaking
easy when is my hand furthest away from
my spine line
here's a Le on a
circle it everyone
understand when is this Jo tip the
furthest away from the East wall at the
what at the 90 got
it before that it's not as long
you see after that it's not as long
either do you
understand if I want to displace
you I would need a weapon that gets
longer not
shorter do you understand that so my my
intention here can't to be
move you
up that can't be can't have your head
come off and my intention can't be to
move you back
okay my intention is to hit this area
with my mass to penetrate the target not
displace the target so this is what I'm
doing okay through here do you
understand that
so and there it's important to do that
because we'll ask this question
now which hand has more mass in it this
one or this
one
why cuz my Mass is closer to the to this
okay so if I extend it it's actually
decreasing
whereas this weapon is very tight and
close and everything hits right here to
alter enough blood pressure here that
the vagus nerve shuts down that's our
okay
here I don't want to extend my arm
okay what I want you to
do is five light ones like that and you
can make their height where it's your
neck height okay and you just
go
okay make your head heart cool and I'm
not going to kill you
but what I'm doing
okay okay maybe if you get if you get a
good one or two that's enough that you
can feel that weight is in if you need
hear the tone like on a drum is deep
okay because there's mass in the hand
okay all right try
it maybe one to three not hard just just
weight in the hand mass in the
hand not momentum mass in the
hand not hitting any other part of the
chest not pushing away into the neck
into the into here hey hey into here not
into the collar B that's a
different not in the collar though right
in thees of the neck or it's
soft you're on the you're on the
collar that's good enough one to three
is good okay the idea
okay this is always how you
do
y same thing he goes boom he goes up and
there it
is elbow drop elbow drop not
around
elbow it's just like
this up no waste of time telegraphing
open here he runs at me with the
shoulder you got it boom you're still
there Boom come around he runs with me
shoulder he defended himself okay don't
give up the new line of
attack for this keep
it boom boom okay same thing he comes
around I want to do Kissa it's showman
turns elbows in that's what turns the
blade not not my hand coming around
okay try go back to the Techni elb it
ends
let's go to medium energy don't hurt
each other you have to slow back down
don't lose the
[Applause]
technique
CH chest the chest
M never grab the Joe as a
priority that's called your cut
you guys got to watch that thing so you
got to kind of move over there or you
could change
sides you actually
start wait on the front
foot same rules on the back foot 90 to
45 45 minimum
Max don't drag it
open
yes draw top of your head elbow
in
good so Chris you're finding it
beneficial at this speed to fade back
right okay so you might find it
beneficial to fade back the m is the m
how you do the
M that's I don't know depends how he's
coming in okay try it
again can't me Jam
and here's what I
need the my is
dynamic it depends on what he does okay
as he's going if he's really running at
me look how I came back you
see if he's not really running at me
then I can come with just leave my foot
there on the
deviation if he stopped got he stop then
I'm going to enter and then come in it
all depends on what he's doing okay try
it again don't have a
set be alive have a living form
draw to the top of your head so it gets
out all the way elbow
in don't let the Joe I don't prioritize
that okay
TR
remember don't Point your tip down he
should knock your tip
down you yielded when you learn he's
coming
straight he
[Music]
softer and
softer less compressed less
compressed if I I'm compressed I have to
go faster okay if I'm compressed it's
because I didn't yield okay try it
again should get easier and easier
softer and softer as long as I'm not
checked he shouldn't came
in get it out of your
shoulder it's in your shoulder
you feel that
pull
yeah should hit air
[Music]
yield so you're not
compressed you got one more deal to do
and you be even less compressed
all
[Music]
right so in that earlier
demonstration you can see what we're
doing is that rotating cross so here I
hold here he's going to go around it and
now he's going to get the AOS but if I
yield to what he's doing he doesn't get
my hands and as long as I stay equal to
his downward pressure not greater but
equal to it he doesn't check my body I
keep contact so no matter where he goes
I can again rotate the cross accordingly
okay so in the second one he came up
like he's going to do shui check me he
brings the weapon up and
boom so he brings the weapon up and I
just follow it up up we'll take this
hand we'll start out slow
again yield I'm stuck he goes up up it
goes and I take this time
into the inward spir
comes his intention follow it up push it
back too
late stay stuck to
wa
boom okay try
[Music]
if you guys leave our room you can move
out from that Alco there tayor we'll
scoot everyone
down let's scoot everyone out of the
ALCO
do a little slow
[Music]
for
okay so we have uh last night these
drills okay
we have it here we're going to see if we
can incorporate it okay so he's doing
his thing I'm doing my
thing boom it goes up it's going to be
here so I'm
going midfoot on the back foot let his
energy come into me shift to the mid
fooot on the front
foot I don't remember that drill three
[Music]
boom notice how my hand isn't going to
come in and then
out
boom four
don't come off the the back
foot you fall into your cemy when you
get that energy all
right it's a little easier if you're
underneath
okay
[Music]
all the weapon
up so find his Center even though the
hand is going up you can find his Center
don't go around his Center because then
you get the live time that's in the 360
of his shoulder Okay so
his arms coming up you see and if I go
around his energy that will take that'll
take it off off the center okay if he's
here and I go over his head the back
will go wherever he is I know it's going
up but you have to move that okay got it
just just like the other drills find the
heaviest part of him and that is what
boom you project okay try not to go
around that part go
he got a little
high find feel his Center
[Music]
you
doing you
CHR did you get a metal B in
slow doesn't matter sometimes they do
both open is on the
[Music]
one
I'm back
br for
[Applause]
okay so uh we're just doing more non
contestation by rotating
across transitioning what was y Yin what
was
y we had an application of the simple
drill three of standing that we did
yesterday
any questions
or observations
it'sot Dynamic cannot be
defined um in in
essence while you might have which foot
is forward all the time like even in Kon
the right foot is supposed to move with
the right hand okay cool but um how much
it moves
is going to be different every time
because no UK can ever repeat the exact
forces nor can you repeat the exact
starting point so even K laa as
controlled and idealized of environment
as it is is pretty Dynam regarding the
mod cannot be
def so sometimes you enter by going
forward sometimes you have the uh 45 to
the angle of
any questions
comments what do you think
I'm I feel like I'm having trouble
closing weapon my in one step
and maintaining my weight in my bank
yeah so he has to
do if I'm here on this line and I'm in
on me okay a couple things one I'm not
in hungry I'm in some sort of
Kam see this and
now my foot can it's going to go
less if I put my foot closer even with
that I can go
fur this is a strategy that is
used indeterminate inititive
I'll I'll lie about them life okay so if
I I'll have them used to me in this
sense see this foot and he learns he's
got about that much but at a certain
point I'll fake that that foot up do you
see and then usually I would use it when
he threw something I say do whatever and
he realizes he's not going to punch and
I do that a few times you see
so on one time I'm he goes and I'm here
you see and when he goes back then I'm
right on him from that okay so how far
apart your back foot is from the front
foot will have how much penetration do
okay that's the first thing the second
thing
is the push drag is further than the set
TR okay so you're going to open your
legs about that
far but you can push past that you see
so I was able to open
it
right and I
can push past it so on this last move
you wore a little shy on the penetration
okay so it's fine it
doesn't and it had to do
that when he came up you were
here he comes up you're stuff in like
that but he comes up shift my weight
push uh and it's just one of those
things I mean I imagine if you were to
calculate it your legs are your leg
length you know what I mean so I imagine
I could probably go past that line but
it gets obviously mechanically unsound
you see and so you don't do it you you
go to here whereas the other one remains
mechanically sound and you can get
across so it's the difference between
the push driver of the
step
um and I think there's a lot of step
driving in modern
IA and that is
uh not
sui just become
sui sui is we translated usually as
Shuffle step but as I said Parker was he
was like a engineer so he would go
that's one Shuffle step and this is
another Shuffle step and so he gave them
different names but in Japanese it's
just Sugi and modern aido has adoped
this one as opposed to the p and it
changes what where the m is and what we
can do with it and also um I would say
it's because we don't modern iido
doesn't need the back foot you see so
they fall off of it and they can just
float on the back foot well if I'm going
to project I need the back foot you and
so we will push drive we won't ever step
off
fo alone uh some gross examples of that
would be the runnery that I
talked have
Ry or sometimes even I would say grer
dud not the
ground not even
ground um and it's all because the step
dag has been normalized as sukashi but
it's not
sui it is a kind of Shuffle but it's not
what sui was supposed to do that would
be my and I I saw that at the end
because you're tall it's not like it
would be me going with Chris out there
but it was still underpenetrated it was
that that
way and I like that you didn't come off
the back foot just to push him you see
well it's very tempting to go
what I'm being told I'm going to push
him and you were like going I'll do the
under penetration instead that's the
right choice between those two things
and then you ask this question and then
you get back to work on the
push all right well done everyone thank
you than